نحمده ونستعينه ونستهديه
ونستغفره ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن
سيئات
اعمالنا من يهده الله فلا مضل
له ومن يضلل فلن تجد له وليا
مرشدا واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا
شريك له له الملك وله الحمد يحيي ويميت
وهو على كل شيء
قدير واشهد ان سيدنا وعظيمنا وحبيبنا
وقائدنا محمدا عبده
ورسوله وصفيه
وخليله بلغ الرساله وادى الامانه ونصح
الامه وكشف
الغمه تركنا على المحجه البيضاء ليلها
كنهارها لا يزيغ عنها الا
صلى الله عليه وعلى اله
الطيبين واصحابه
اجمعين ومن سار على نهجهم الى يوم
الدين اخص
بالذكر امراء المسلمين
بالحق ابي بكر وعمر وعثمان
وعلي ورضي الله سبحانه
وتعالى عن السبطين
الحسنين
الاحسن الحسن
والحسين وعن حمزه
والعباس وعن ازواج النبي امهات
المؤمنين الطاهرات من الادناس
والارجاع بنات النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم زينب ورقيه وام كلثوم
سما قره عين الرسول فاطمه الزهراء
البتول ورضي الله سبحانه وتعالى عن السته
البرره الذين هم تمام العشره
المبشره وعن بقيه الصحابه والقرابه
والتابعين ومن تبعهم باحسان الى يوم الدين
رضوان الله تبارك وتعالى علينا وعليهم
اجمعين
فيا عباد
الله اوصيكم ونفسي المذنبه الخاطئه بتقوى
الله تعالى وطاعته ولزوم اوامره وكثره
مخافته اطيعوا الله والرسول لعلكم ترحمون
ايها المؤمنون واعلموا عباد الله ان
التقوى شعار المؤمنين ودثار الصالحين
ووصيه الله تعالى في وفيكم اجمعين فقد قال
الله سبحانه
وتعالى اعوذ بالله السميع العليم من
الشيطان
الرجيم بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله
ولتنظر نفس ما قدمت لغد واتقوا الله ان
الله خبير بما
تعملون ولا تكونوا كالذين نسوا الله
فانساه
انفسهم اولئك هم
الفاسقون لا يستوي اصحاب النار واصحاب
الجنه اصحاب الجنه هم
الفائزون صدق الله
العظيم اما بعد ايها
المؤمنون خطبه
اليوم
حول رعايه الاولاد في
الاسلام قال الله سبحانه
وتعالى وما بكم من
نعمه فمن
الله وقال عز
وجل وان تعدوا نعمه
الله لا
تحصوها اعلموا عباد الله
ان من افضل
النعم التي امتن الله بها على
عباده ان جعلهم
مسلمين ومن اهل
التوحيد وان هناك
نعما خص بها فئه من
الناس وحرمها فئه
اخرى امتلاء منه سبحانه
وتعالى وتمحيصاً
[Silence]
او يزوجهم ذكرانا
واناثا ويجعل من يشاء
عقيما انه عليم
خبير صدق الله
العظيم فمن اعظم النعم على
الانسان بعد نعمه
الاسلام نعمه
الولد ولا سيما
الولد
الصالح وانتم
تعرفون ان لفظ الولد اذا جاءت في القران
الكريم يراد بها الذكر
والانثى نعمه
الولد لا يعرف
قدرها الا من حرم
منها فكم من الناس
من منع نعمه الابوه
والامومه
فتراه يسعى
جاهدا ليلا
ونهارا بكل ما اوتي من جهد
ومال
للحصول على الولد الذي
فقده
ولكن قدره الله سبحانه
تعالى فوق الطاقات والاموال
المهدره لانه
سبحانه
عليم
قدير يختبر
العباد ويمتن على
الانسان
فيمن حرم
الولد اصبروا
وصابروا
ورابطوا واتقوا الله لعلكم
تفلحون قال الله سبحانه
وتعالى المال
والبنون زينه الحياه
الدنيا فال
الاولاد فلذات
اكبادنا وقره
عيوننا قال صلى الله عليه واله وصحبه
وسلم وان لولدك عليك
حقا رواه الامام
مسلم فاحذروا ايها
الناس من التفريط في تربيه
الابناء او
التخلي عن المسؤوليه تجاههم
قال رسول الله صلى الله عليه واله وصحبه
وسلم
انما يرحم الله من عباده
الرحماء متفق
عليه فاتقوا الله ايها
الاباء في فلذات
الاكباد ولا
ظلم
ابنائكم والاساءه
اليهم ثم بعد
ذلك تطلبون صلاحهم
وطاعتهم
فذلك النقيض
وضده ولا يلتقي
النقيضان
وربما كان هناك
اباء فقدوا زمام التربيه
فانحل
ابناؤهم وضاع
اولادهم فلم
ينصاعوا
لاوامر
وهذا
امر مشاهد
وملموس في مجتمعنا
هذا نتيجه المشاكل بين الزوجين
وهذان الزوجان لم يتبعوا المنهج الاسلاميه
المحمديه
الصحيح نرى ان
اولادهم يخرجون من
البيت ويتعاطون
المخدرات
والخمر
ولربما للبنت صديقا في الجامعه او في في
الثانويه وللولد ايضا مثل
ذلك فلذلك
يكون
الاباء قد ضيعوا
اولادهم تراهم في
الطرقات وفي
السيارات ضياع
وتيه وتعرفهم بسيماهم
هؤلاء الاولاد وهذه العائله التي تدعي
الاسلام شرهم اكثر من
خيرهم قال ابن القيم رحمه
الله من
اهمل تعليم ولده ما ينفعه وتركه
سدى فقد اساء اليه غايه الاساءه
واكثر الاولاد انما جاء فسادهم من قبل
الاباء
واهمالهم لهم وترك تعليمهم فرائض الدين
وسننه فاضاع
صغارا فلم ينتفعوا
بانفسهم ولم ينفعوا
ابائهم قال
القائل عود
بنيك على الاداب في
الصغر كي تقر بهم عيناك في
الكبر
فانما مثل
الاداب
تجمعها في عنفوان الصفه في عنفوان الصبه
كالنقش في
الحجر ان
الغيور ليتساءل
كيف لاب
وام انيطت بهما امانه
عظيمه ينامان قرير
العين يكتحل
بالنوم م الا جفنيه ما
وابناهما خارج
المنزل فقولوا لي بالله بربكم اي
اب اي ام
هذان واي تربيه
تلك الا ترون
هذين
يحتاجان الى ادب
وتربيه
بلى كيف
للاولاد ان
يصلوا اذا كان الاب والام لا
يصليان كيف
للاولاد ان يلتزم باوقات
الصلاه اذا كان الابوان يضيعان
الصلاه قال
تعالى ومن
اظلم ممن ذكر بايات ربه فاعرض عنها ونسي
ما قد مت يداه انا جعلنا على قلوبهم اكنه
ان يفقهوه وفي اذانهم وقرا وان تدعهم الى
الهدى فلن يهتدوا اذا
ابدا فلا بد اخي المسلم من رعايه الشباب
والناشئ حتى يكونوا نواه
صالحه لدينهم ومجتمعهم
سيما
وانتم ايها
المسلمون وانتم سفراء الاسلام في هذه
البلاد فاتقوا
الله معشر العباد واحفظوا وصيه الله لكم
في
الاولاد
وتذكروا موقفكم يوم
المعاد لا يغني مولا عن مولا شيئا ولا هم
ينصرون
فانتم مسؤولون عن انحراف
الشباب ومحاسبون عن
تربيتهم امام رب
الارباب قال تعالى
وقفوهم انهم
مسؤولون عن معقل ابن يسار رضي الله عنه
قال
سمعت النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
يقول ما من عبد استرعاه الله
رعيه فلم يحطها
بنصيحه الا لم يجد رائحه
الجنه ارعوا
ابنائكم وادوا
اماناتكم وصحوا لاولادكم
فكل مسؤول عن
رعيته لذا ايها الاخوه والاخوات
ادعوكم ان تربطوا اولادكم
الشباب
بالمسجد وادعو الشباب
انفسهم الى ان يواظب في
المسجد وتشجع الاخرين على المش
في البرامج التي نقيمها لاجلهم
ليكونوا دعاه
صادقين وعلماء
ربانيين ورجال
مؤثرين يخدم دينهم
وعقيدتهم مثل ما كان شباب وابناء
الصحابه والسلف الصالح رضوان الله تبارك
وتعالى عليهم اجمعين
وليكونوا لكم صدقه
جاريه عن ابي هريره رضي الله
عنه ان رسول الله صلى الله عليه واله
وصحبه وسلم
قال اذا مات
الانسان انقطع انقطع عنه عمله الا من
ثلاثه الا من صدقه جاريه او ينتفع به او
ولد صالح يدعو له رواه الامام مسلم رحمه
الله تعالى ربنا هب لنا من
ازواجنا وذرياتنا قره اعين واجعلنا
للمتقين
اماما واستغفر الله العظيم لي ولكم
ولوالدي ولسائر المسلمين اجمعين ادعوا
الله وانتم موقنون
بالاجابه ‏e